[Musique]
en 2002 les français découvrent y'a que
la vérité qui compte une toute nouvelle
émission présentée par pascal bataille
et laurent fontaine
plusieurs saisons d'animateurs vont
recevoir des anonymes cacher derrière
ils devenus faire une déclaration
importante un invité de leur choix
quelqu'un veut vous parler quelqu'un qui
a quelque chose d'important à vous dire
ce soir c'est le personnel est là les
rencontres surprises qui peuvent donner
lieu à des moments d'émotion et d'amour
[Musique]
mais aussi à des moments un peu gênant
lorsque la météo refuse de rencontrer
l'autre personne venue sur le plateau on
ai parlé je vais laisser le rideau fermé
ce soir le programme signe son grand
retour sur ces 8 pascal bataille et
laurent fontaine sont avec nous sur le
plateau pour livre cette émission
[Applaudissements]
sans déconner n'avait pas sans lui vous
avez la même tête les deux
et maintenant non franchement j'aurais
dit si vous aviez pris un coup ici on
s'en fout totalement le dire toute la
vérité sinon franchement lui un peu
quand même non mais alors lui
mais ça va non tabac alors c'est vrai
campus à l'épaule droite tout le monde
disait ya le petit et le grand mais il
n'y a pas de petits parce que l'eau
roland petit après c'est pascal qui est
très grand 1 95 à 90 et ça non mais
c'est sympa ton on disait il ya le petit
laurent mais en fait il ya l'autre est
grand et le bien voilà c'est ça la
normale et le normal est exactement mais
c'est ça pour ça valait chéri vous êtes
content très heureux mais ça revient ce
soir sur s'est vite on y croit
énormément avec si vite raconté à nos
téléspectateurs ce qu'on va voir ce soir
les histoires les plus on a gardé
quelques séquences parmi les 800
histoire qu'on ait fait en cinq ans un
croyant on a choisi celle qui nous ont
fait le plus marrer surtout c'est qu'il
ne pouvait être plus pleurer et celle où
il ya eu des des clients absolument
incroyable et des personnalités
absolument incroyable voilà donc des
plateaux c'est remonter ses recettes et
à l'image donc tu voir ses traits
booster ses très gros alors et le
programme c'est très réussi je le dis
franchement il ya du verso est il devenu
oui on a retrouvé on a retrouvé certains
des participants et qui nous racontent
ce que ça a changé dans leur vie de
passer dans l'émission et où il ya des
belles surprises on va pas spoiler le
truc mais on va se rendre compte que
c'était pas tout à fait anodin de passer
dans cette émission ce sera juste après
tout je peux m'en passer à vous faire du
bien on va voir ça je vous dis est ce
qu'on a besoin aussi de voilà de voir
des trucs qui nous font du bien et c'est
vrai que c'était moi c'est une émission
que je ne ratais jamais même j'étais fou
de cette émission non mais c'est vrai je
pense que c'était je lui je pense
c'était une de mes émissions préférées
achètent et j'étais comme un fou dans
l'es21 pas vous franchement a été tout
aussi incroyable c'est que c'est des
images qui ont 15 ans mais ça a pas
vieilli ça pourrait se passer
aujourd'hui l'émission elle pourrait
dater d'aujourd'hui c'est toujours aussi
fort et franchement j'ai vraiment la
mission elles reviennent en inédit aussi
alors je me rappelle vous étiez souvent
caricaturé 1 les guignols vous appelez
un cerveau fonde à l'époque c'est
toujours comme ça quand on cartonne
voyez au palais on a plein sur tf1 ils
n'ont pas ce problème
[Rires]
qu'avec bataille et fontaine bateau
irene était bondée merci messieurs vous
êtes donc au coeur d'une polémique
génial génial super oui vous êtes
totalement responsable fo moi je suis
responsable de bataille et moi je suis
responsable de fontaine bataille et
fontaine
babacan et rien ne peut vous arrêter
rien si la pub mais plein de fric les
pubs trop courts les janvier
[Applaudissements]
c'est très drôle et niall après plus du
tout ouais et après plus du tout de la
ccsa et pour le dire une chose nous dit
on s en fout 808 son témoignage par
l'émission 10 ans et cela lui 110 par on
a des 1600 demandes par mois de gens qui
voulaient pas sur le plateau on faisait
le tri 11 et les enquêtes machin mais
super 1600 personnes qui voulaient
passer comment vous avez une idée c'est
un format où vous avez une idée tous les
deux en fait on cherchait une émission
où on puisse essayer de rendre service
aux gens on a regardé pas mal de
l'émission qui se faisait ailleurs et on
est tombé sur une émission allemande une
émission italienne une émission
espagnole où il y avait des choses
intéressantes on a fait un mix de
richard show case au finish et tout et
on a créé on a rajouté pas mal de choses
dont sam dont les écrans le rideau qui
n'existaient pas et c et puis et puis à
la fin on a quand même racheté les
droits de l'émission italienne pour pas
avoir de problème de de plagiat mais ce
qui fait qu'on a perdus nous les droits
de l'émission restent donc c'est plus à
vous les moyens et de l'émission si nom
de l'émission
tu veux tout titre
cyril se réveille à le coup d'état faire
non mais sérieux ocde gens sérieux là
haut mais ça va non mais moi j'ai
franchement pour moi je crois que série
l'émission la plus culte de ces années
là je le dis franchement non mais
c'était moi je nomme je n'en ratez pas
une c'est un vrai rendez vous lundi soir
vers 22h50 sur terre le vrai truc sur
ses émissions c'est que les gens
regardaient ça comme on garde friends ou
décès suspect sial entre copains entre
amoureux entre amis assuré que j'espère
que sur ces 8 on aura pour elle devait
faire des communautés qui malade a cédé
soir à mykonos d'aurillac l'année
c'était génial c'était génial jamais
surveillé padrino en revanche
au monde ouvre et tout le monde c'était
magnifique jusqu'à
ce que la chaîne est ce que tf1 il ya
cru tout de suite oui ce qu'ils vous ont
dit c'est vous allez dans le muret la
chaîne ya d'ailleurs ils y croient
toujours pas et heureusement que
vous l'avez repropose à tf1 mais bien
sûr je dis non mais bien sûr une très
belle
avec toutes les mères devraient en vrai
on arrêtait ya pas photo à l'époque on
avait fini son escale pendant cinq ans
et en fait à tf1 dont c'était pas top et
j'ai déjà raconté jean luc delarue dû
arriver de france 2 et tf1 il fallait
faire la place cour fait quoi je fais
court et donc il nous auriez vous savez
quoi vous avez encore un contrat de
trois émissions affaire fait nous genre
n'importe quoi ils sont même pas venus
je crois aux réunions à l'époque et on a
balancé ça l'antenne tranquillement un
combat et le largage matin à 9h 3g eu
etienne mougeotte qui m'a appelé qui m'a
dit papa carton c'est si vous vous tenez
un truc génial on va signer ça pour l'an
prochain voilà c'est franchement mais
c'est vrai que c'était un énorme carton
et c'est devenu c'est devenu culte moi
j'ai envie de voir comment ça s'est
arrêté pourquoi ça s'est arrêté à
clavières éthiquement puisque les
saisons c'était quand même elle se
maintenait à
co2 énigme pour moi à l'époque de thèmes
et en plus vous étiez producteurs aussi
un moment est plus plus c'est y'a que la
vérité qui compte est la méthode qu
israël à arrêter on n'a pas compris
pourquoi ça cartonne actuellement
pourquoi ce
nom et ce qui s'est passé c'est que tf1
globalement avec des audiences qui
faiblissent et déjà voilà je ne lis plus
elle serait c'est plus féminin
et ils ont eu le sentiment il y avait
une nouvelle direction aussi qu'ils
prenaient un peu le tour ils ont une
forme steam ans qu'il fallait tout
changer et qu'il fallait tout
révolutionner malheureusement ils n'ont
jamais retrouvé des missions qui fasse
ses scores là et puis soyons cachant ce
public un gros concurrent qui s'appelle
docteur house par exemple louis plus
qu'écouter car en pin le bout là où des
éditions de tf1 jean recourbé genre nous
coûter beaucoup plus cher et ça serait
aussi a eu la balle du nouveau tf1 après
après que nos jeunes sont partis alors
c'est vrai que c'était moi moi vous
adoriez moi je voudrais qu'on voit la
vidéo la première émission donc c'était
le 10 juin 2020 homme aux mille 2 juin
2002 lancé en juin je me rappelais plus
loyaux pas s'il en est c'est ce qu'il
faut regarder c'est le test et ça a
était combien vous rappelez l'audience
ou pas oui on a fait 48 % chez les
ménagères 3 millions 8
deux personnes individu est
incroyable
pour toi
toutes les personnes que nous allons
recevoir son ce plateau ne savent pas
pourquoi elles sont habilitées avec nous
ce soir et savent tout simplement c'est
ce que notre équipe leur a dit que
quelqu'un avait quelque chose à leur
dire et oui quelqu'un a quelque chose à
leur dire mais qui est venu leur parler
puis surtout quelle est cette vérité
qu'on va leur révéler ce soit bien nos
invités donc l'ignorent totalement ils
pourront le découvrir évidemment s'ils
décident d'ouvrir notre rideau serait
donc est en train de se refermer
derrière
ça du fait des pressions l'intérêt de
cette mécanique c'est qu'on peut tous
passer dedans aussi bien des trucs qui
te hérisser les poils que des trucs qui
te faisait marrer et c'est ce qu'on va
voir ce soir mais il y avait toutes ou
de certaines émotions vous allez
regarder alors ce soir il ya quatre
témoignages forts sachez que les vidéos
elle cartonne aussi sur les réseaux sur
youtube sur tik tok et je vous montrer
la vidéo la plus visionnée sur youtube
c'est c'est damien iehl marina marine a
fait beaucoup de mal à damien la
travailler avec un autre homme en prison
a refusé les demandes en mariage de
damien et leurs trouvailles avait donné
un moment très très fort sur le gâteau
c'est la vidéo qui a fait le plus de
vues regard des gilts aurait pu avec
fatou toi oui un torride et 300 et elle
aurait jamais ouvert le rideau de ce que
damien vous voulez que on regarde qui
est de l'autre côté de ce rideau hall
entier oui
est-ce que c'est ce visage que oui vous
vous attendiez à découvrir mais c'est
fidel qui je voulais malheureusement pas
avoir en face de moi mais que j'ai à
damien je sais que je t'ai fait beaucoup
de mal et si je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est pour te demander pardon tu m'as
demandé en mariage était refusé une fois
deux fois et là je suis là pour te dire
que je suis prête à épouser et chercher
une maison ensemble et qu'on ait des
enfants aujourd'hui j'ai vraiment pour
lui tu te faire du mal si jamais vous
dites en faire malheureusement pour
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vouloir retenter
quelque chose
est-ce que damien à kiel accepté
d'ouvrir le rideau ce qui l'accepté ou
pas c'était ça le moment climax je
demande et rideaux paris oui nous on
sait où vous vous le saviez vous alors
on savait pas jamais on ne rompt s'est
passé parce qu'on connaît l'histoire
mais malheureusement
vous me posez vos illusions moi je sais
pas non mais c'est toi qui sont ces gens
diraient
non mais parce qu'on l'a on l'a revue
plein de séquences qu'on avait pas vu
depuis quinze ans aurait tué récemment
décroché comme on dit dans le milieu non
mais moi là là là déjà je suis dedans
j'ai envie de savoir la tribune d'hier
battu mais j'ai dressé tu peux pas t'en
vas qu'est ce que tu dis là ils mettent
une pub là tf1 à l'époque tu es obligé
de regarder de regarder pour l'instant
les chauffeurs routiers
[Rires]
[Musique]
décidé par rapport à j'étais énormément
de blessés j'ai essayé de faire tout le
mon mieux pour pouvoir la garder et ce
qu'ils aient jamais réussi que
maintenant que je suis une fois je suis
parti et qui veut revenir c'est vrai que
c'est sa plus belle chose qui pouvait me
faire c'est ça mais malheureusement je
t'offrirai
chez les hauts les marais n'achète pas
repartir si ça m'a fait trop de mal et
ça m'a troublé c'est là je sais que ça
va te faire du mal depuis ce que je te
dis mais non
là je suis d'autant plus que ça je suis
sûr que ça va cartonner gif appareils
benjamin castaldi genre eu du pif 1
voilà et pour cela vers ce met d'accord
mais écoutez quand on le regarde on vous
fait plus confiance qu'à moi c'est
certain mathieu et moi je n'ai aucun
doute qu'ils croient vraiment mais aussi
des soins moi c'est un truc tout bête
est ce que j'ai
et j'ai envie de regarder donc je vois
là je suis là j'ai envie d'en voir un
autre garde et j'aimerais voir ce moment
fort c'est lorsqu'un jeune homme
lorsqu'une jeune femme city revoit son
ex qui est venu lui faire un discours
talent un gars en campagne
présidentielle ça c'était très très
drôle mais regardez tu te souviens je te
disais toujours que j'irai partout
partout pour te dire que je t'aime
et ce soir devant la france entière
l'afrique du nord l'hérault
même l'afrique vers chez nous tous ceux
qui ont des cannes
rien que pour te dire que je t'aime j'ai
changé c'est vrai je reconnais mon temps
je sais que j'étais bon dit je sais mais
je
je reconnais tout ça t'a jamais su au
fait que j'étais mais là au point de
deux tons ministre sur le plateau d'une
télévision c'est y essaie de contrôler
que je t'aime il est coincé contre moi
on a tous envie de savoir s'il a été
convaincant quoi est-ce qu'il a ouvert
le rideau va regarder
par mail ce que je peux te dire je ne
peux plus parce que je suis avec une
autre personne dont ce naître moment et
je ne peux plus voilà
ah c'est bien dommage je n'aurai plus
rien à faire ici tu sais très bien que
c'était pour t'acheter venir quand je
vais rentrer au pays
je repars si simple est-ce que j'ai bien
compris que vous laissez ce rideau fermé
ce soir oui je vous remercier et vous
laisser repartir tranquillement merci
d'avoir écouté ce que art mais là j'ai à
vous dire
ça c'est normal c'est le
professionnalisme de pascal on a bien
compris que
ça ça me rappelle mon rappel mais une
émission qui voudraient bien fait
d'ailleurs l'île de la tentation certes
été tranquille sera pesté jean louis
toujours ça je vous raconte toujours
stévia les dégâts donc allez sur une île
et qu'elle espère chauffé par d'autres
9es avec l'animateur donc j'étais comme
ça mais il avait un petit ipad comme ça
et il avait eu cette phrase qui avez
vous vu qu'elle est moins
le gac et sur l'île avec des maps il
est en train de
s'adapter sur l'autre lidl à y regarder
je vous montrer une vidéo d'eux
qu'avez vous vu cabinet entendu je viens
de voir qui est bouffé le plus de
maréval
et le gars étaient très sérieux je me
rappelle un et tu l'a été d'ailleurs
laurent way we sur tulle avait fait état
des années vient d'annoncer pascal il
reste apparemment il ne va pas ouvrir le
rideau mais c'est ça en fait et c'est ça
qui marchera pas alors c'est vrai je
pense que s'il y avait un animateur qui
déconnait trou maintenant il faut je
pense que ça aurait pas marcher bien sûr
et ses savants fighters a fait savoir
exactement l'euro qui pouvait faire de
l'amour qui était chaleureux qu'ils
étaient et puis moi il fallait que je
fasse que se tiennent la baraque et que
quelques jeux réconforte aussi un peu
l'élan vous aviez démarré avec avec
christophe dechavanne huawei il va
revenir à l'antenne christophe direct
sera notre invité d'ailleurs la semaine
prochaine salamé bon courage à lui ça va
mais c'est
vrai qu'il a lancé plein cauchemar
kiki d'annoncer plein de monde
christophe lui faire un bisou à mon
christophe et je lui ai dit je le sens
bien et je suis content de le recevoir
la la semaine prochaine nos parrains
pour vous c'est vraiment laisser votre
parent c'est le plus grand pour vous ou
non or pour moi oui ouais ouais plus
grand que quoi on tombe pas en tant
qu'animateur normes et 2 2 2 de notre
époque oui
mais là je vais doit refléter graves
comme intrusion mais christophe moi
c'était nous on arrête moi derrière
dechavanne corée en 2000 et toi depuis
dix ans il y avait aussi un croyez vous
êtes des braises encore ma nous était
pas animateur voûté l'antenne trois
heures de chavannes personnes faut que
cesse ce que tu fais personne ne le fait
voilà nous on est des animateurs non
mais c'est important de le rappeler
c'est pas la même chose mais rien coûté
en tout cas moi je te dis moi dis voici
en tout cas c'est bien content parce que
j'ai dit que je voulais le rappeler sur
christophe revient à l'antenne est serré
qu'il a lancé un mondial oui des mois et
des mois que tu fais le travail mais
qu'il fallait beaucoup parlé voilà et
c'est vrai que moi je le sens bien ce
soir et vous êtes resté pas tous pas
tous les deux il ya plein de gens qui
nous demandent mais oui vraiment d'être
resté on est en été on est tous c'est
très bien parce qu'on se connaît depuis
très très longtemps
on était potes avant de travailler
ensemble c'est ce qui a fait que
effectivement cette complicité cette
complémentarité elle n'était pas feinte
elles n'étaient pas fabriqués et les
gens le sentent et je crois donc on est
resté pote oui très très longtemps après
on s'est un peu engueulé
pour des histoires de politique à la
noix et puis on est et aurait été copine
avec pascal toi bah oui
faire qu'elles soient commises avec moi
vous aimez quand t'es quoi face et c'est
comme les histoires de yack la vérité
quand il ya deux frères ou deux
émissions ça et puis 37 ans pascal et
moi durant sans élégance vous
connaissiez avant vous êtes reconnus
comme mandela avant d'être né sans être
connus on s'est rencontré un concours de
jeunes journalistes
moi je suis monté sur scène pour
recevoir le prix constants il draguait
ma copine
je connais bien je connais bien le
rennais personal name intense mais chez
moi quand tu reçois un prix laurent mais
sert il faut toujours se méfier de lui
mais ça va a nommé laurent il discute
seulement c'est un homme qu'elle a
discuté et la réplique à channing de
communication mais voilà c'est vrai
juste série que non mais l'idée ou es ce
que vous avez envie de refaire aussi de
6 et 8 vous dis on va refaire la vérité
qui montre qu'avec que des nouveaux cas
est ce que vous leur faites ou pas bien
sûr mais avec
avec beaucoup de précaution parce que tu
sais y'a un truc qui a beaucoup changé
et tu te tapes renverser les réseaux
sociaux des chiens il faut se dire que
quand on arrêtait l'émission au fait
vous car existait depuis deux ans ça
paraît invraisemblable mais c'est vrai
et il faudrait qu'on fasse très
attention à protéger les gens qui
passerait dans l'émission de du
déferlement de haine elle doit faire le
mans 2-2 commentaires pas forcément
voilà parce que c'est des gens qui
viennent pas juste passer à la télé ils
venaient parce qu'ils avaient un vrai
besoin et ils sont pas là pour recevoir
derrière des tombereaux de méchanceté
voilà donc faudrait se méfier de ça vous
avez dit qu'on se connaît depuis très
longtemps 3 et c'est vrai qu'il ya
jérôme revon et stéphane gâteau qui
m'avait appelé comme producteurs et ceux
qui m'ont appelé en premier vraiment
dans les premiers aussi pour travailler
avec moi pascal et laurent je me
rappelle j'étais venu vous voir à votre
bureau va gagner on sent un truc on sent
que c'est un truc qu'on aimerait
travailler vous savez sur youtube c'est
qu'on se trouvait avec avec anna vous
savez pas qui anime une émission la
méthode cauet l'époque j'y passe à
maurice jeannelle c'est peut-être la
fédé des retournements de plateaux et
des shows pandémie de loups ils doivent
appeler et puis voilà on a failli faire
un truc ensemble je pense pas maintenant
quand on fait un truc à trois c'est très
bien on le sait très bien